foreign
[Music]
T spotted kissing La Brea actor Jack
Martin oh that's sweet check out Lily at
LAX
she holds her man's face as he grabs her
waist and they share a smooch before she
catches a flight racing and hugging well
of course Lily's most recognized as her
role as Betty on Riverdale what if he
escaped
are you out there while Jack's known for
his work on La Brea there are a few
bright sides I must say no saber tooths
no walls that might kill us and he's got
a solid following on Tick Tock Alexa
play my favorite poetry
[Music]
some fans they think Jack looks a whole
lot like Lily's ex and Riverdale co-star
Cole Sprouse whatever you need to do or
explore
I support you turns out Jack's a fan
well kinda he shared this Riverdale
inspired Tick Tock last year with the
caption I love this show we have third
period math together cool yeah I'll see
you then want to know why the FBI said I
was too dangerous to work with
because I finally collected enough
vampire Shadow Demons from the
underground maple syrup Labs of
Riverdale which makes me Immortal but
the parodies don't end there why did the
relationship with your girlfriend end I
don't want to play anyone if that bit
feels familiar it's because it's Jack
doing his best cold why did the
relationship end
I won't go into that too much but I will
say it was Mutual yeah Cole went viral
earlier this year for his interview on
call her daddy Jack saw it and took the
opportunity to find the funny
impersonating the Riverdale star's
Essence and outfit even smoking to
really drive it home when I come on your
podcast unbutton my shirt all the way in
chain smoke American Spirits and I'm
gonna Cole's yet to speak out about
Jack's impression but one thing we
imagine he and Lily do have thoughts
about Riverdale ending after seven
seasons this is the most important piece
of reporting that I've read Riverdale
the final season when you just went back
to work stepping on set did it feel
different than all the times before it
does it does it has a Bittersweet
feeling to it and I think I'm kind of
just trying to approach this season with
uh not taking anything for granted
really trying to be present trying to
enjoy my co-stars so it is it's
different for me at least but as one
chapter ends another begins
thank you